est ce qu'on peut faire je peux prendre
gilles verdez puisque gilbert dess vous
allez découvrir votre défi tout de suite
allez-y gilles vous pouvez partir avec
les équipes regardé l'émission de
télé-réalité rival à quoi il va rester
comme ça à vous inquiétez pas c'est
regarder on va tout de suite voir ou
valve et gilles verdez et je vais vous
expliquer ce qui va se passer pour
gilles verdez s'il vous plaît franco
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir l'image de
dehors s'il vous plaît regardez qui est
là françois hollande c'est françois
hollande
vous vous rappelez françois hollande a
eu un souci lors de la marche
républicaine il s'est fait il s'est fait
déféquer dessus par un pigeon oui c'est
vrai et françois hollande m'a appelé et
il m'a dit cyril je suis énervé après ce
pigeon et je veux me venger et bien
gilles verdez va être déguisé en pigeons
dans un instant il va partir vers le
ciel à 30 mètres de haut françois
hollande sera sur une nacelle et devra
lui ajouté est le bien le viser comme
lui l'a visée voilà de la fiente de
pigeon c'est la revanche de notre
président ce soir et ne touchent pas
ce qui se passe vers la mort
mais là je vais passer vous avez
conscience et pro chez elle alors vous
allez voir ce set alors c'est juste pour
vous dire sachez que le dernier prime de
la saison ce sera la revanche des
chroniqueurs et pourrait me faire
j'avais promis ses premiers juré craché
gilles verdez sera sur une nacelle il va
s'élancer à plus de 30 mètres gilles
verdez et sachez le il y aura donc il
sera déguisé en pigeons regardez ça va
bouger nous ça va moyen série lh ça va
moyen avoisine un moyen ça va moyen non
ça va sinon ça va aller chez nous oui
vous inquiétez pas on est là là françois
hollande qui vous surveille
ramos il ou non mais je l'adorent
rapprochement il est armé
parce qu'ils y croient ils étaient
illettrés courage au général vraiment et
il est plus courageux de valérie bella
une panne et on va aller tout de suite
rejoins de gilles verdez gilles verdez
savamment gilou gilles qu'étant pigeon
sera bogino alors si c'est pas très
grave vous inquiétez pas vous il ya
françois hollande qui est là vous l'avez
vu françois frey les eaux il nous faut
soir c'est pas il a l'air là haut mais
presque aux palois reproche à françois
hollande qui opèrent en brocart merci
merci franck parce que françois françois
detton mais ce qu'on peut voir will est
vraiment parce qu'on n'arrive pas à se
rendre compte là en fait
est ce qu'on peut voir un petit peu oui
dès ce qu'on peut faire un pari il est
sur une voie là exactement
donc françois hollande et la voilà la
corse y ait ce qui peut nous saluer
monsieur le président voilà merci mais
mon sosie dans l'ouest
dans un instant on aura gilles verdez
qui nous fera le saut notre gilles
verdez qu'on aime gilles verdez et notre
héros gilles verdez on laine et françois
hollande vous saviez que françois
hollande s'il s'est fait tuer déféquer
dessus par un pigeon lors de la marche
républicaine et françois hollande dans
la quête ici veut prendre sa revanche
merci merci françois alors c'est très
simple le jeu très simple gilles verdez
va s'élancer gilles est ce que vous êtes
bien l'attacher mon chéri j'espère cyril
est ce que parce qu'en fait j'ai
confiance quand vous cyril est ce que
vous le pouvez vérifier leur demander
que je suis bien attaché mais c'est
quand même un peu bizarre mais alors
dans les chairs est ce qu'il est
vraiment bien la tâche et je vous jure
que c'est vrai et là ça me fait peur
franchement oui
vous êtes sûr vous avez vérifié en régie
sur un vous inquiétez pas j'ai alors je
peux vous le demandez autre chose syrie
quand on y viendra partir comme la
dernière fois vous pourrez faire un
décompte
d'accord vous voulez m'angoissait gilou
je vous aime trop mouillé ou savamment
sur ina vous aime aussi je vous l ai dit
non mais je ne voulais pas qu'on voulait
pas qu'on annule donc sans déconner la
chaloupe à nancy je suis bien attacher
divers analogue à la tâche et nature il
est bien la tâche et les gars ou pas
derrière j'ai déconné là
je vous jure est je vous jure je
commence à flipper franchement je
commence à flipper bon et moi aussi
penser à auguste mon filleul d'accord
j'ai décollé la série je crois non après
non oui vous allez décoller mais pas
grand chose hier françois hollande qui
va vous visez il veut sa revanche
vous avez un truc à dire à françois
hollande salopards la ola 2017
jjg l'houmeau syrie donc je passe le
décompte des ouvriers à bouliac vous il
ya que vous attention il se sera la
seule chose que vous ferez ce soir alors
j après je vous laisserai tranquille
mais ce sera qu'un amusement
non mais j'y vienne pas voulait vraiment
génial ou pas oui c'est rigolo de la
saison michel salaün attention 5
[ __ ]
5-4 je vais croire je veux pas voir ça
au [ __ ] moi non plus appathurai et les
corps mais pas de version
sa maman
l'image est magnifique ode à pigeon
devant des beats à sa 3e voie sa maman
gilou chéri va très bien je suis plein
de fientes